rejoignez-moi sur patronne pour accéder
à l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
est-ce qu'on peut dire qu'il pourrait y
avoir une autre vision c'est pas celle
que j'ai ou finalement le mal et le fait
de faire du mal aux autres la jungle à
la loi de la jungle la plus la plus pure
et dure serait pas l'essence même de la
vie
il faudrait revenir à cette violence là
à cette libération de la violence pour
rétablir l'ordre des choses tout à fait
bah là actuellement je travaille sur un
épisode sur la loi du plus fort
justement donc c'est pour ça tout à
l'heure je te parlais de qualicles et
Socrate la loi du plus fort ben la
première version philosophique de la loi
du plus fort c'est dans le gorgiase de
Platon avec le personnage de calicless
qui est une sorte de précurseur de
Nietzsche
et en gros
ce que qualicless explique c'est une
idée très simple
et d'ailleurs assez intuitive c'est pas
c'est pas délirant toujours pareil sur
le papier c'est pas délirant mais c'est
dans les faits faut voir ce que ça donne
en gros il explique que ce qui régit la
nature c'est la compétition et que les
plus forts survivent
et c'est très bien comme ça
c'est pas que c'est très bien c'est que
c'est comme ça
donc partons du principe que c'est voilà
si c'est comme ça et que dans une vision
antique on considère que la nature a ses
raisons
la nature ne fait rien en vain et que
pour que la nature existe pour la nature
s'est fusils c'est le monde pour que le
monde existe il faut quand même qu'il
soit régi par quelques lois quels qui
respectent un équilibre en tout cas il
faut qu'il y ait un équilibre le
l'existence présuppose la viabilité donc
une forme d'équilibre nécessaire à
l'existence et que donc si la nature
fonctionne comme ça l'être humain
lui-même devrait fonctionner comme ça et
on devrait pas limiter
le désir naturel des individus on
devrait les laisser entrer en
compétition et donc
on calclès voilà soutient la loi du plus
fort d'ailleurs il se fait un peu
prendre au piège par Socrate qui dit
matin et pour la loi du plus fort mais
qui est le plus fort le petit nombre ou
le grand nombre
alors quelle classe tu réponds bah le
grand nombre évidemment
sauf que si le grand nombre est
constitué par des faibles tu te
retrouves à défendre les faibles contre
la minorité de fort
ceux qui sont pour la loi du plus fort
mais qui dénonce la coalition des
faibles
et la réponse de Socrate c'est de dire
bah les gars vous avez choisi le critère
de la force si les faibles se coalise et
qui deviennent plus fort vous devez
assumer c'est eux qui deviennent fort
ouais c'est ils prennent la place voilà
chacun va aller chercher la force là où
il peut donc la force du nombre ça
existe tout ça pour dire que voilà
qualicles défendait cette vision là et
Nietzsche par la suite et les
darwinistes sociaux eux sont ceux qui
ont vraiment
formalisés le principe en gros de la
sélection naturelle mais ils l'ont
appliqué aux sociétés en disant la
compétition et le moteur du progrès
c'est une vision alors compétition on
peut l'entendre au sens compétition
économique c'est le capitalisme
on peut l'entendre aussi au sens
physique et pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas simplement ce n'est pas la
trajectoire qui a suivi notre
civilisation et je pense même que pour
qu'il y ait civilisation il faut qu'il y
ait loi c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'il y
ait
principe commun
et que le principe commun il est
forcément contraignant
on peut pas laisser la liberté naturelle
de chacun s'exprimer si on veut qu'il y
ait société maintenant tout va dépendre
de ton anthropologie c'est à dire de ta
vision de l'homme à l'état de nature
c'était du côté de Rousseau
tu vas dire finalement l'homme est ta
nature il était très bien il était très
bon plutôt il était innocent
c'est-à-dire
non nos sang non nocif
et c'est la société qui finalement la
corrompue en instituant le règne de la
représentation et donc tout ce qui
s'ensuit c'est-à-dire l'hypocrisie la
concurrence le vice ça c'est Rousseau
hop ça va dire non non l'homme est ta
nature il est violent c'est un loup pour
l'homme donc il fallait la force de la
loi la force de l'État pour faire
rentrer un peu tout le monde dans le
rang sans quoi
l'humanité ce serait autodétruite
donc selon l'anthropologie qui est la
tienne tu vas te dire ok soit les êtres
humains sont capables
de vivre les uns avec les autres et que
même si on met de la compétition ça ira
ou même si ça va pas c'est comme ça puis
à ceux qui diront non non il faut mettre
des lois sinon ça fonctionne pas un peu
ce que disait freud disait voilà nous
sommes tous des névrosés parce que nous
vivons tous avec l'autorité de la loi
qui nous empêche d'accomplir nos désirs
fondamentaux
donc on a tous une espèce de de filtre
qui correspond à la limite de la loi et
c'est un peu ça qui nous rend dingue
quoi c'est à dire on réprime des
pulsions et c'est ça qui crée aussi
les tueurs en série par exemple ou les
criminels de toutes sortes
voilà on réprime cette pulsion animale
les les Grecs avaient une solution que
j'aime beaucoup
c'est que ils avaient la loi et puis ils
avaient aussi les ils avaient les les
fêtes cathartique au cours desquelles on
avait le droit d'assouvir un peu toutes
ces pulsions et sa libérer
voilà on intégré le dionysiaque dans la
polymience c'est-à-dire on intégré la
pulsion dans la raison on la maîtrisant
la licence exprimer je veux dire si les
boîtes de nuit existent avec tout ce que
ça comporte de nocivité sociale
c'est-à-dire
alcoolémie violence accident de voiture
des gars sur la santé tout ce que tu
veux c'est parce que c'est libérateur
c'est parce que tu as certaines
personnes une soupape voilà bon donc ça
existe encore de nos jours
la question c'est est-ce qu'on le cadre
où est-ce qu'on le cadre pas
peut-être que si tout était permis
peut-être qu'on se permettrait moins de
choses mais ce qui était le principe du
film la purge je sais pas si tu l'as vu
ce film ça il y a eu le 1 le 2 après
c'est ils en ont tous évidemment ils en
ont plein de fuite mais c'était vraiment
ce principe là c'est on va prendre une
journée ou une nuit je sais pas dans
l'année tout est permis on libère tout
pour qu'ensuite les 380
360 je sais pas combien dans une année
les autres jours de l'année tout tout le
monde se comporte à merveille et la
société fonctionne encore mieux il y a
une logique derrière ça je dis pas et
voilà c'est là où le le militant se
prononcerait moi je me prononce pas
parce que
parce que j'en sais rien
le militant c'est celui qui qui prend
ses projections pour la réalité
j'en sais rien de ce que ça donnerait et
ça me dérange pas de ne pas savoir ce
que ça donnerait parce que c'est pas le
cas parce que ce n'est pas ce qui est et
que ce n'est pas ça qui est sur le point
de devenir si demain il y a un
effondrement bancaire mondial et qu'on
se retrouve dans une situation qu'on va
qualifier de chaos
à ce moment là on verra ce que ça donne
on saura on aura un exemple sous les
yeux de ce que ça donne et encore ce
sera un chaos qui aura été prédéterminé
par tout un contexte je veux dire l'état
de nature c'est pas forcément le chaos
ça peut être l'harmonie ça peut être
aussi longtemps l'intelligence
l'entraide l'entraide a énormément joué
dans l'évolution humaine le l'ouvrage de
croupotine là-dessus je trouve
passionnant parce que ça vient rétablir
un petit peu la balance de cette idée de
compétition il n'y a pas que de la
population violent voilà il y a de la
coopération parce que la coopération est
nécessaire à la sortie de l'espèce et
que et que l'individu ne peut vouloir
exprimer sa toute puissance que dans un
contexte où la survie de la communauté
est déjà garantie
mais dans un contexte où la survie de la
communauté et de l'espèce n'est pas
garantie il y a déjà beaucoup moins
d'individualisme parce que tu as besoin
du groupe
simplement donc ce qui est le reliquat
de de la pression sociale de se faire
rejeter d'un groupe ou quoi qui vient
qui vient de là qui vient de
complètement qui viendrait si on a une
grille de lecture
évolutionnaire sur les
comportements sociaux
l'exclusion nous ramène à l'isolement du
groupe qui peut être la cause de notre
mort physique
l'abandon l'abandon c'est pas juste
c'est pas juste psychologique l'abandon
c'est physique d'ailleurs tu te démerdes
et c'est pas toujours facile de se
démerder
donc le l'appartenance au groupe est
vraiment fondamental dans la psychologie
humaine y compris de nos jours même dans
des sociétés individualistes
parce que ça nous ramène quand même à
cette interdépendance qui définit la
condition humaine
ce que les Aristote
Aristote disait s'il disait l'homme est
un animal politique alors moi je me suis
longtemps posé la question mais
qu'est-ce qui veut dire par la politique
dans quel sens politique dans le sens
qui s'intéresse à la politique non c'est
politique au sens de social l'homme est
un animal social qui a besoin des autres
donc si tu as besoin des autres tu peux
pas te permettre non plus de tuer
prochain voilà comme ça simplement parce
que tu en as eu l'impulsion
à moins de considérer que l'homme n'est
qu'un animal parce que l'homme est un
animal oui est-ce qu'il n'est qu'un
animal je réponds que non
parce que c'est un animal conscient de
l'être donc capable de se hisser au
dessus de son animalité ce qui fait déjà
une grosse différence et même les
animaux ne sont pas si sauvages que
l'image qu'on en a ils peuvent l'être et
ce qui est d'ailleurs un argument de
ceux qui défendent
pas l'anti-évolutionniste mais de dire
que finalement on peut s'élever de tout
ça que les comportements on peut les
changer pour
pour
être au mieux et qui ne correspondent
plus à nos nos réflexes ancestraux nos
réflexes archaïques
c'est toujours la question du curseur et
aussi de la direction
voilà là tiens voilà je vais te donner
ma position pour le coup ma position
c'est que
l'être humain est un animal
conscient qu'il est plus qu'un animal et
c'est ça qui fait toute la différence
autrement dit
on a eu besoin de se comporter comme des
animaux pendant des millions d'années
pour pouvoir survivre même si animal ne
veut pas dire violent égoïste et sauvage
voilà mais simplement on a on obéissa
des réflexes instinctifs de survie
qui ont pu un moment donné aussi
entraîner une forme de
rudesse d'agressivité quand c'était
nécessaire de manque d'empathie aussi
quand ça pouvait pénaliser le groupe
parce que je veux dire l'empathie
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus facile
que quand on était des chasseurs
cueilleurs et que bon ben si tu as
si tu as le pépé des chasseurs
cueilleurs je sais pas quel âge il
pouvait avoir à l'époque mais qui se
blesse et que tu as le choix entre
rester là pour le secourir au risque que
les fauves viennent te tuer ou le
laisser là parce que il faut il faut se
il faut survivre il faut s'échapper et
ben non pas tir à ce moment-là
c'était forcément un frein à l'évolution
à l'adaptation et et à la survie tout
simplement donc le manque d'empathie a
pu être nécessaire pour l'humanité et
pour ton ennemi tu es mort
lui il en aura peut-être pas et puis
c'est terminé bah c'est ça c'est à dire
que l'empathie est un privilège
civilisationnel
et et tant mieux je veux dire tant mieux
qu'on est ce privilège parce que bon
forcément on est des on est implanté
dans une époque il est normal qu'on lise
le monde à travers la grille de lecture
de notre époque moi je suis davantage
pour l'empathie que pour l'indifférence
je suis davantage pour la générosité que
pour l'égoïsme mais c'est facile pour
moi parce que qu'est-ce que je risque à
dire ça
peut-être que si demain tu me mettais
dans un environnement sauvage avec trois
gus comme moi et qu'à un moment donné il
fallait se battre pour récupérer la
fourrure de l'animal je te dis pas que
je défendrai l'empathie
je peux le faire que parce que ma
position sociale est civilisationnelle
me le permet et aujourd'hui c'est très
souvent ce qu'on fait on Lille passer à
travers la lunette du présent pour dire
ah mais on était des animaux on était
des monstres quelque part on devrait
avoir honte de ce que nous sommes mais
c'est ce dont tu as honte c'est à dire
cette partie de toi-même qui te
constituait aujourd'hui qui fait que tu
existes qui qui fait que tu es là oui ça
veut ça c'est souvent ce que je dis
faire ce que je dis ce que j'ai
l'impression on peut pas être un gras au
point d'oublier ça maintenant
règle puisque justement la société a
évoluer super intéressant et c'est
toujours le truc du progress entre
progressisme
je cours progresse jusqu'où on est on
est on est naturel
l'aquiliné tout ça tu vois tout à fait
quels sont les comportements
dont on a eu besoin auquel on a eu
besoin de recourir par le passé pour
survivre qui ne sont plus indispensables
aujourd'hui qui ne sont même plus utiles
pour survivre aujourd'hui pour évoluer
aujourd'hui pour vivre heureux
aujourd'hui quelles sont ses
comportements archaïques dont on peut se
défaire et je dis pas les Reniers et en
avoir honte parce que ça n'a pas de sens
dire est-ce que tu as eu est-ce que tu
as honte aujourd'hui d'avoir sucé ton
pouce quand tu avais deux ans
c'est débile c'est pas parce que à 30
ans tu suces plus ton pouce a priori que
tu vas avoir honte de l'avoir fait quand
on avait deux parce que ce qui était
une étape un moment donné de ton
développement n'est plus cet état
attendez développement actuel bon bah
c'est la même chose pour pour l'humanité
et donc
l'enfant suce son pouce le Homo sapiens
ça lui recours au cannibalisme
aujourd'hui j'irai pas manger les restes
de mon voisin
si j'ai de la viande dans mon
réfrigérateur parce que la question de
se pose pas parce qu'on a la morale de
sa situation matérielle parce que c'est
facile quand on vit dans une maison
climatisée en été et chauffée en hiver
avec un réfrigérateur plein de se poser
la question de la moralité
ou de l'immoralité de la violence
mais la morale elle évolue en fonction
de nos conditions matérielles
d'acceptation et je suis contre le
jugement rétrospectif de ce que nous
avons été sous prétexte que nous ne
sommes plus maintenant voilà il y a tout
un tas de choses dont on peut se défaire
progressivement et je dis bien
progressivement parce qu'on ne on
n'appuie pas sur la touche RESET 2
millions d'années d'évolution
[Musique]